thank you
all right
not great
[Music]
okay
okay
thank you
huh
oh yeah
[Music]
yes
all right
yeah but the thing is like
even like next
little parrots
are you happy
all right
okay
[Music]
is
you know
um
okay
uh
so
this
and
here
here
[Music]
just
i
okay
so
[Music]
see
all right
hello
it's
foreign
he's so serious
okay
[Music]
like
two
[Music]
okay
yes
hey okay
[Music]
oh
everybody
so
uh
[Music]
this
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
thirty
[Music]
i
like
[Music]
wow
thank you
let's go
so
so
[Music]
see
this
foreign
so
so
[Music]
um
bye
uh
okay
so
so
huh
so
[Music]
the select committee to investigate the
january 6 attack on the united states
capitol will be in order
without objection the chair is
authorized to declare the committee in
recess at any point
pursuant to house deposition authority
regulation 10
the chair announces the committee's
approval to release the deposition
material presented during today's
hearing
good morning
last week the select committee laid out
a preview of our initial findings about
the conspiracy overseen and directed by
donald trump
to overturn the results of the 2020
presidential election
and block the transfer of power
a scheme unprecedented in american
history
my colleagues and i don't want to spend
time talking about ourselves during
these hearings but as someone who's run
for office a few times i can tell you at
the end of a campaign
it all comes down to the numbers the
numbers tell you the winner and the
loser
for the most part
the numbers don't lie
but if something doesn't add up with the
numbers you go to court to get
resolution
and that's the end of the line
we accept those results
that's what it means to respect the rule
of law
that's what it means to seek elective
office in our democracy
because those numbers aren't just
numbers
they're votes
they're your votes they're the will and
the voice of the people
and the very least we should expect from
any person seeking a position of public
trust
is the acceptance of the will of the
people
win or lose
donald trump didn't
he didn't have the numbers he went to
court he still didn't have the numbers
he lost
but he betrayed the trust of the
american people
he ignored the will of the voters
he lied to his supporters and the
country
and he tried to remain in office after
the people had voted him out
and the courts upheld the will of the
people
this morning
we'll tell the story of how donald trump
lost an election
and knew he lost an election and as a
result of his loss decided to wage an
attack on our democracy
and attack on american people by trying
to rob you of your voice in our
democracy and in doing so
lit the fuse that led to the horrific
violence of january 6
when a mob of his supporters stormed the
capitol
sent by donald trump to stop the
transfer of power
today
my colleague from california miss
lofgren and our witnesses will detail
the select committee's findings on these
matters
but first i will recognize our
distinguished vice chair ms cheney of
wyoming for any opening statement she
cared to offer
thank you very much mr chairman
last week as the chairman noted our
committee began outlining a seven-part
plan overseen by president trump to
overturn the 2020 election
today we will begin looking at the
initial part of that plan
president trump's effort to convince
millions of americans that the election
was stolen from him by overwhelming
fraud
a federal court has already reviewed
elements of the committee's evidence on
this point
and said this quote
in the months following the election
numerous credible sources from the
president's inner circle to agency
leadership and statisticians
informed president trump and dr eastman
that there was no
election fraud close quote sufficient to
overturn the 2020 presidential election
the court's opinion methodically
documents each of the principal reasons
for that conclusion and i would urge all
those watching to read it
today we will begin to show the american
people
some of our evidence
today you will hear much more from a
former attorney general bill barr's
recorded testimony
and you will hear in greater detail what
others in the department told president
trump that his claims of election fraud
were nonsense
you will also hear much more from
president trump's own campaign experts
who had also concluded that his fraud
claims could not be supported
let me focus briefly on just three
points now
first
you will hear first-hand testimony that
the president's campaign advisors urged
him to await the counting of votes and
not to declare victory on election night
the president understood even before the
election that many more biden voters had
voted by mail because president trump
ignored the advice of his campaign
experts and told his supporters only to
vote in person
donald trump knew before the election
that the counting of those mail-in
ballots in several states would not
begin until late in the day and would
not be complete for multiple days this
was expected reported and widely known
you will also hear testimony that
president trump rejected the advice of
his campaign experts on election night
and instead followed the course
recommended by an apparently inebriated
rudy giuliani
to just claim he won
and insist that the vote counting stop
to falsely claim everything was
fraudulent
he falsely told the american people that
the election was not legitimate in his
words quote a major fraud
millions of americans believed him
second pay attention to what donald
trump and his legal team said repeatedly
about dominion voting machines
far-flung conspiracies with a deceased
venezuelan communist allegedly pulling
the strings
this was quote complete nonsense as bill
barr said
president trump's own campaign advisers
his department of justice and his cyber
security experts all told him the same
thing
here for example is white house lawyer
eric hershman
his view was shared by many of the trump
team whom we interviewed
i thought the dominion stuff was
i never saw any evidence whatsoever to
sustain those allegations
and third as mike pence's staff started
to get a sense for what donald trump had
planned for january 6 they called the
campaign experts to give them a briefing
on election fraud and all the other
election claims
on january 2nd the general counsel of
the trump campaign matthew morgan this
is the campaign's chief lawyer
summarized what the campaign had
concluded weeks earlier that none of the
arguments about fraud or anything else
could actually change the outcome of the
election
generally discussed on that topic was
whether the
fraud male administration
abuse or irregularities
uh if aggregated and read most favorably
to the campaign would that be outcome
determinant
and
um i think everyone's assessment in the
room at least amongst the staff mark
short myself and greg jacob was that it
was
not sufficient to be outcome determined
as is obvious this was before the attack
on the capitol
the trump campaign legal team knew
there was no legitimate argument fraud
irregularities or anything to overturn
the election
and yet president trump went ahead with
his plans for january 6th anyway
mr chairman hundreds of our countrymen
have faced criminal charges
many are serving criminal sentences
because they believed what donald trump
said about the election and they acted
on it
they came to washington dc at his
request
they marched on the capitol at his
request
and hundreds of them besieged and
invaded the building at the heart of our
constitutional republic
as one conservative editorial board put
it recently quote
mr trump betrayed his supporters by
conning them on january 6 and he is
still doing it
another conservative editorial board
that has long supported president trump
said last week donald trump quote won't
stop insisting that the 2020 that 2020
was stolen even though he has offered no
proof that that is true
and this
donald trump now quote clings to more
fantastical theories
such as dinesh d'souza's debunked 2000
mules
even as recounts in arizona georgia and
wisconsin confirm trump lost
those are the correct conclusions to
draw from the evidence gathered by this
committee
we have much more evidence to show the
american people on this point than we
can reasonably show in one hearing
but today we will begin
thank you mr chairman i yield back
without object
without objections the chair recognizes
gentlewoman from california the
slaughtering for an opening statement
well thank you mr chairman in our
opening hearing we gave an overview of
our investigation into the january 6th
attack the plot to overthrow the
election was complex and had many parts
which we'll explore in remaining
hearings but today we examine the false
narrative that the 2020 election was
quote stolen former president trump's
plan to overturn the election relied on
a sustained effort to deceive millions
of americans with knowingly false claims
of election fraud
all elements of the plot relied on
convincing his supporters about these
false claims
today we'll demonstrate the 2020
election was not stolen the american
people elected president joe biden will
present evidence that mr trump's claims
of election fraud were false that he and
his closest advisers knew those claims
were false but they continued to peddle
them anyway
right up until the moments before a mob
of trump supporters attacked the capitol
we'll also show that the trump campaign
used these false claims of election
fraud to raise hundreds of millions of
dollars from supporters who were told
their donations were for the legal fight
in the courts but the trump campaign
didn't use the money for that the big
lie was also a big rip off
the former president laid the groundwork
for these false claims well in advance
of the election
as early as april 2020 mr trump claimed
that the only way he could lose an
election would be as a result of fraud
you know the things with bundling and
all of the things that are happening
with
votes by mail
where thousands of votes are gathered
and i'm not going to say which party
does it but thousands of votes are
gathered and they come in and they're
dumped in a location and then all of a
sudden you lose elections that you think
you're going to win the only way
we're going to lose this election is if
the election is rigged remember that
it's the only way we're going to lose
this election this is going to be a
fraud like you've never seen did you see
what's going on take a look at west
virginia mailman selling the ballots
they're being sold they're being dumped
in rivers this is a horrible thing for
our country
this is not there's no this is not going
to end well
mr trump decided even before the
election that regardless of the facts
and the truth if he lost the election he
would claim it was rigged
mr trump was right about one thing
it did not end well
on election night mr trump claimed even
before the votes were counted that his
loss was a result of fraud
on thursday we had testimony from
attorney general barr about the
department of justice investigation of
mr trump's fraud claims
barr told trump directly that his claims
were bs
yet after hearing the truth and that
warning from the ag mr trump continued
to peddle the false claims of fraud
you'll hear detailed testimony from
attorney general barr describing the
various election fraud claims the
department of justice investigated he'll
tell you how he told mr trump repeatedly
that there was no mirror to those claims
mr barr will tell us that mr trump's
election night claims of fraud were made
without regard to the truth and before
it was even possible to look for
evidence of fraud
attorney general barr wasn't alone
you'll see and hear today other
department of justice officials and
senior advisers to mr trump that they
told him the claims he was making were
not supported by evidence
the election fraud claims were false mr
trump's closest advisors knew it mr
trump knew it
that didn't stop him from pushing the
false claims and urging his supporters
to quote fight like hell to quote take
back their country
after he lost the election various legal
challenges were made you'll hear
testimony today from a renowned
republican election litigation lawyer
who explained the normal process by
which candidates challenge an election
rather than accept the results of the
election and the decisions of the courts
mr trump pursued a different strategy he
tried to convince the american people
the election had been stolen
many of his supporters believed him and
many still believe him today
the attack on january 6 was a direct and
predictable result of mr trump's
decision to use false claims of election
fraud to overturn the election
and to cling
to power mr chairman i yield back
thank you very much i now welcome our
first witness
we're joined today by former fox news
politics editor chris stylewalk
bill stephen president trump's former
campaign manager was subpoenaed to be
here and was in washington this morning
prepared to testify
kevin moreno
mr stephen's attorney is here with us
today
thank you mr mourinho for coming
and he was advised uh he has advised us
that mr stephen's wife
went into labor this morning mr stephen
unexpectedly
had to travel to be with his wife and we
wish him the best
due to the depth and rigor of our
investigation
with several hours of mr stefan's
testimony from when we interviewed him
in february and we will be presenting
that testimony today
i'll now swear in our witness
the witness will please stand and raise
his right hand
do you swear our firm on the penalty of
perjury that the testimony you're about
to give is the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth so help you god
thank you
you may be seated
let the record reflect the witness
answered in the affirmative
i now recognize myself for questions
i want to start by showing a video that
tells the story of what was going on in
the trump white house on election night
in november of 2020.
do you remember where you were on the
night of the election november the 3rd
i was at the white house
you know where specifically over the
course of that night you spent your time
within the white house
there
was an event that was organized in the
residence so i moved between
um
the
residence
a room sort of off the residence
where some family members were i take it
the president was upstairs in the
residence
he was upstairs i was we were kind of on
the first floor so not uh upstairs with
uh
mostly with ivanka and her brothers and
a couple other people who'd be coming in
now can you just describe the atmosphere
what were people expecting
that night when you got to the white
house
i think that there was
typically for people who show up there
on election night it's gonna be a
self-select more positive environment
i think people were a little bit nervous
not knowing what was going to
happen with the red wave or the red
mirage as the debate was being carried
out
the fox news decision desk is calling
arizona for joe biden
that is a big get for the biden campaign
arizona's call do you remember that
what do you remember happening
uh where you were when arizona was
called
um i uh there was a surprise at the call
who was surprised
most most everyone in the room
were you being one of them
yes
did that shift the atmosphere or the
attitude
in the white house
completely
how so can you describe that
because
fox news was the first one to go out and
say that
so was it anger kind of directed towards
fox news for making a call more so than
a disappointment that maybe the campaign
lost
arizona
all the above
still both anger and disappointment
uh both disappointing with fox and
um
concerned that maybe
our data or our numbers
weren't accurate were you in the white
house residence during the
sort of past midnight into the early
morning hours of november 4th
uh yeah so sure it went over beyond
midnight yes
do you remember rudy giuliani being at
the white house on election night and
into the early hours the next morning
i do
what do you remember about when he came
um
he
he was
there were i had heard that he was uh
upstairs you know in that aforementioned
uh reception area
and
he was looking to talk to the president
and it was suggested instead that he'd
come talk
uh to
several of us um down off the map room
you said that mr you had heard that mr
giuliani wanted to talk to the president
and then he was directed your way did
you end up talking to mr giuliani when
he was directed
i did what was that conversation
a lot of conversations were directed my
way
a few of us
myself
jason miller
justin clark and mark meadows
gathered
[Music]
in a room off the map room
to
to listen
to whatever
rudy presumably wanted to stay for the
president
was there anyone in that conversation
who in your observation had had too much
to drink
uh
mayor giuliani
tell me more about that what was your
observation about his
uh potential intoxication during that
that discussion about
what the president should say uh when
he's addressed the nation on election
night
and the mayor was definitely intoxicated
but i did not um
know that his level of talk intoxication
when he spoke uh with the president for
example were you part of any discussions
uh with uh the people i mentioned mr
steffi and mr meadows or anyone else
about whether the president should make
any sort of speech on election night
i i mean i i spoke to the president
they may have been present but um
president
spoke to the president several times
that night
there were suggestions
by
i believe it was mayor giuliani to go
and declare victory and say that we want
it outright it was far too early to be
making any calls like that
um
ballots
ballots were still being counted
ballots were still going to be counted
for days
um and it was far too early to be making
any proclamation like that
i remember saying that
i to the best of my memory and i was
saying that we should not go and declare
victory until we had a better sense of
the numbers
okay can you be more specific about that
conversation in particular what mayor
giuliani said
your response and then anybody else in
the room's response
i think effectively mayor giuliani was
saying we want it
they're stealing it from us where'd all
the votes come from
we need to go say that we won
and
essentially that anyone who didn't agree
with that position was being weak
what was your view at the time as to
what he should or shouldn't say
i don't know that i had a firm view
as to what he should say
in that circumstance
the results were
still being counted
um
it was becoming clear that the race
would not be called
um
on election night my belief
my recommendation was to
say that
votes were still being counted
it's too early to
to to tell
too early to call the race
but um
you know we uh
proud of the race we've we run we ran
um and
we
you know
think we're i think we're in a in good
position
um and we'll have more to say about this
you know the next day or the next day
whenever we had something to say
and did anybody who is a part of that
conversation disagree with your message
yes
who is that
the president disagreed with that
i don't recall the particular words he
thought i was wrong
he told me so and uh
you know that they were gonna you know
go in into a he was going to
go in a different direction
this is a fraud
on the american public
this is an embarrassment to our country
we were getting ready to win this
election
frankly we did win this election
mr steinwald did president trump
have any basis to declare victory on
november 4th 2020
thank you
mr stephen also testified that president
trump
had no basis for declaring victory
at that point in time
by
my belief
my recommendation was to
say that
votes were still being counted
it's too early to
to to tell
um too early to call the race
but um
you know we uh
proud of the race we've we run we ran
um and
we
you know
think we're i think we're in a in good
position
and we'll have more to say about this
you know the next day or the next day
whenever we had something to say
thank you
uh
the style after the votes were counted
who won the presidential election
of 2020
joseph robinette biden jr of the great
state of delaware
thank you
that's the bottom line
we've had an election mr trump lost
but he refused to accept the results of
the democratic process
pursuant to section 5c 8 of house
resolution 503
i now recognize the gentlewoman from
california miss lofgren for questions
well thank you
thank you mr chairman mr shirewold i'd
like you to explain a turn that was
thrown around a lot during the election
and that's the so-called red mirage what
does that mean
so
in the 40 or 50 years let's say that
americans have increasingly chosen to
vote
by mail or early or absentee
democrats prefer that method of voting
more than republicans do so basically in
every election republicans win election
day and democrats win the early vote and
then you wait and start counting and it
depends on which ones you count first
but usually it's election day votes that
get counted first
and you see the republicans shoot ahead
and then the process of bailing and
binding and unbinding all those mail-in
votes
and some states like pennsylvania refuse
to count the votes first so you have to
wait for all of that to come in so in
every election and certainly a national
election you expect to see the
republican with a lead but it's not
really a lead
when you put together a jigsaw puzzle it
doesn't matter which piece you put in
first it ends up with the same image so
for us
who cares uh but that's because no
candidate had ever tried to avail
themselves of this quirk in the election
counting system we had gone to pains uh
and i'm proud of the pains we went to to
make sure that we were informing viewers
that this was going to happen because
the trump uh campaign and the president
had made it clear that they were going
to try to exploit this anomaly and we
knew it was going to be bigger because
the percentage of early votes was higher
right we went from about 45 percent of
the votes being early in absentee
because of the pandemic that increased
by about 50
so we knew it would be longer we knew it
would be more so we wanted to keep
telling viewers hey look the number that
you see here is sort of irrelevant
because it's only a small percentage of
these votes so this red mirage that's
really what you expected to happen on
election night happens every time
thank you mr steinwald i'd like to play
a a clip of attorney general bill barr
who also explains what was expected to
happen on election night
right out of the box on election night
the president uh
claimed that there was major fraud
underway i mean this happened
as far as i could tell before there was
actually any potential of looking at
evidence and it seemed to be based
on the dynamic that
that
at the end of the evening a lot of
democratic votes came in which changed
the vote counts in certain states and
that seemed to be the basis for this
broad claim that there was major fraud
and
i didn't think much of that because
people had been talking for weeks and
everyone understood for weeks that that
was going to be what happened on
election night
mr stephen obviously could not be with
us today and it's proper for him to be
with his wife as they welcome their
child
but he also had discussions
with the president about the red mirage
that is that it would be a long night
and that early votes would favor him but
lots more votes would be counted over
the course of the night and the days
after so let's play
uh clip one
from our interview with mr stephen
i i recounted back to that conversation
with him
in which i said just like i said in 2016
was gonna be a long night um i told him
in 2020 that
um you know there were it was going to
be a process again
um as
you know the early returns are going to
be you know positive and we're going to
you know be watching the returns of
ballots as
you know they rolled in thereafter
so is it fair to say you're trying to
present a
what you thought would be a realistic
picture of what might happen over the
course of that night being election
night
that night in the days that followed
yeah i
i i always uh
i always you know
i always told the president the truth
and uh you know i i you know i think he
expected that for me and uh i told him
it was going to be a process it was
going to be
um
you know um you know
had to wait and see how this turned out
um so i just like i did in 2016 i did
the same thing in 2020.
so let's watch a short clip of president
trump speaking after he received that
information from his campaign advisors
we want all
voting to stop
we don't want them to find any ballots
at
four o'clock in the morning and add them
to the list
so when former president trump said that
it contradicted what his advisors had
warned would happen
we all know that male imbalance played
an important role in the 2020 election
however president trump continuously
discouraged mail-in voting
mr stephen was so concerned about the
president's position on mail-in voting
that in the summer of 2020 he met with
president trump
along with house minority leader
kevin mccarthy let's play clip four
meeting uh that was had um in particular
um
i invited uh kevin mccarthy to
join the meeting
uh he being of like mind
on the issue
uh with me
um in which we
made our case
uh for
for why
we believed
mail-in balloting mail-in voting um
not to be a bad thing for his campaign
um
but um you know the president's mind is
was made up and
you understand um
you know how many times to you know go
to the well on a particular topic
yeah i understand tell me a little bit
more about the argument that you and mr
mccarthy made
to the president in that meeting as to
why it wasn't a bad thing that mail and
voting was available
largely two pillars to that argument
both of which i've
previously mentioned
one you know leaving a good deal of
chance
pushing or uh
urging your voters to vote only on
election day
leaves a lot to chance uh that's that's
a
and b uh also previously mentioned
um the fact that
the trump campaign republican national
committee the republican party had an
advantage of of grassroots workers and
volunteers on the grounds that would
allow
you know an advantage
to enhance return rates of ballots that
were mailed those were the two
yeah pillars of the argument i say and
what if anything do you recall
representative mccarthy saying during
that meeting
we were we were echoing the same
argument i mean his
his words
echoed mine and vice versa on those on
those two topics
mr starwell you were at the decision
desk at fox news on election night and
you called arizona early for president
biden which was controversial
how did you make that call and where did
you think the race stood in the early
hours of the next day
well it was really controversial to our
competitors who we beat so badly by
making the correct call first uh our
decision desk was the best in the
business and i was very proud to be a
part of it uh because we had a we had
partnered with the associated press and
the national opinion research center at
the university of chicago uh thanks to
uh my colleague and friend arnon mishkin
uh had built a wonderful device for
forecasting the outcomes of elections so
we had a different set of data than our
competitors did we had more research
and we had a better system and we had a
great team
um so what you're waiting to see is do
the actual votes match up with the
expectations in the poll the real votes
are testing the quality of your poll in
targeted precincts and in targeted
places and let me tell you our poll in
arizona was beautiful and it was doing
just what we wanted it to do and it was
cooking up just right and at some point
and i forget
exactly
who
but at some point it became clear that
arizona was getting ready to make a call
so we around uh you know my boss bill
salmon said we're not making any call
until
everybody says yes because that was
always our policy union ammonity and you
have to understand or in this room you
have you know the the best people from
academia democrats republicans a broad
cross section of people who had worked
together for a decade were really
serious about this stuff so we knew it
would be a consequential call because it
was one of five states that really
mattered right wisconsin michigan
pennsylvania georgia arizona were the
ones that we were watching we knew it
would be significant to call any one of
those five but we already knew trump's
chances were very small and getting
smaller based on what we had seen so
we were able to make the call early uh
we were able to beat the competition uh
we looked around the room everybody says
yay and on we go and by the time we
found out how much everybody was
freaking out and losing their minds over
this call we were already trying to call
the next state we had already moved on
we were into georgia we were in north
carolina we were looking at these other
states
so we thought it was we were pleased but
not surprised i see
you know after the election as of
november
7th
in your judgment what were the chances
of president trump winning the election
after that point yes none
i mean i guess there you could you it's
always possible that you could have
you know a truckload of ballots be found
somewhere i suppose but once you get
into this phase you know um ahead of
today i thought about what are the
largest margins that could ever be
overturned by a recount and the normal
kind of the kind of stuff that we heard
mike pence talking about sounding like a
normal republican that night and he said
you know we'll keep every challenge
nothing like that in a recount you're
talking about hundreds of votes
when we think about calling a race one
of the things that we would think about
is is it outside the margin of a recount
and when we think about that margin we
think about in modern history you're
talking about a thousand votes 1500
votes at the way way outside normally
you're talking about hundreds of votes
maybe 300 votes that are going to change
so the idea that through any normal
process in any of these states remember
he had to do it thrice right he needed
three of these states to change
and in order to do that i mean you're a
you're at uh an infant you're better off
to play the powerball uh than to have
that come in
on november 7th the other major news
outlets called the race for president
biden now mr stephen told the committee
that he thought the odds were and this
is a quote very very
very bleak
and held a meeting with the president
that same day let's uh show clip eight
video clip eight
i mean with each day that we're on i
mean
the trajectory of the race
on election night trump ahead
um in in many states
and as as that week wore on as the third
became the fourth became the fifth
and so on and so forth and the vote by
mail ballots were tabulated you know
trump's trump's lead you know
grew more narrow
and and and in
some places biden surpassed you know
trump in the vote totals
so as as the week wore on
um as we paid attention to those numbers
every single multiple times a day um you
know internally um you know i
i was feeling less confident for sure
what was your view on the state of the
election at that point
um you know uh very very very bleak um
you know i i
we we told him um
the group that went over there um
outlined you know
my belief in in chances for success at
this point and
and then we pegged it at you know five
maybe maybe ten percent based on
recounts that were that that you know
either were automatically initiated or
or could be um could be initiated um
based on
you know realistic legal challenges not
all the legal challenges that eventually
were pursued
um but you know it was uh
you know
my belief is that it was a very very i
mean five to ten percent
it's not a very good optimistic outlook
now as president trump and others
continue to claim that the election was
stolen
there were lawyers who were a part of
the campaign campaign lawyers who were
responsible for investigating the fraud
claims
that includes alex cannon who could not
validate the claims that were being made
including those being made by the
president
let's
roll video 15
13. this is an email
it's two emails actually the first is
from alex cannon to you and faith
mcpherson
and then you forward that email onto uh
mark meadows justin clark and jason
miller the subject being a z federal id
voters
um if you look at the original email
there it says bill we completed the az
analysis you requested i assume that's
about arizona
and because of the uh the substantial
uncertainty surrounding the databases
this is a highly unreliable way to
identify ineligible voters can you
explain the task that you gave to ms
cannon
um for this
arizona analysis
sure um
previously i um
described some of my frustration with
some of the claims that people would
throw at president trump
regarding you know
you know you need to look at this you
know this happened in this state or that
happened in that state and it would be
you know those would flow to us
um to look into i talked about that
before i think
you know
this is an example of that i recall
i recall um
in arizona someone had
thrown out i believe this to be the
claim that there were
thousands of
illegal citizens
people not eligible to vote having cast
their ballots in arizona
someone had thrown out that claim to
president trump
and with
you know the margins being as close as
they were as i previously described you
know
that could potentially matter um
so this
wild claim is thrown out which you know
on his face didn't seem
you know realistic or possible to me
um
i asked alex
to
look at the
you know the the claim
and i
i haven't read this full email but i
recall the the response
to that
um
the reality of that was not illegal
citizens voting in the election i think
it was like overseas voters voting in
the election i i
saw obviously you know people who were
eligible to vote
when these findings were passed up the
chain to president trump he became
frustrated
and he replaced the campaign's legal
team
let's play clip 14.
you know i think the president um it was
during the second week where things like
you displayed returning where he was
you know growing uh increasingly and
happy
with um
his team
you know me
less so because i was less involved at
this point
but still me um
growing increasingly and happy with
justin clark
um and that that kind of
you know um
you know paved the way for you know
justin to be moved out and married
julian to be moved in as the person in
charge of
you know the legal side of the campaign
and for all intents and purposes
campaign at that point
now when mr stephen became
campaign manager he was the second
trump campaign manager for the 2020 race
and there were only about 115 days
until election day so let's play uh
the video
i inherited a campaign that was
the day i was hired was
i believe president trump's low point in
the 2020
daily average polling against president
obama it was uh it was a campaign at a
low point in the polls
um it was um
structurally and fiscally deficient
um
you know i
you know there was a great deal wrong
with the campaign in in both of those um
in both of those areas
um so most of my day
spent fixing what
i think i took over with 115 days left
in the campaign most of my time spent
fixing the things that could be fixed
with 115 days left in the campaign
now mr stephen
has been in the campaign field for a
long time
and he worked for lots of different
candidates and campaigns he testified to
this committee
about his concerns given the claims that
mr giuliani and ms powell and their team
were making a publicly let's play clip
15.
okay and was it important for you mr
stephen to sort of pull back just for
your own
professional reputation you didn't want
to be associated with some of what you
were hearing from the giuliani team and
others that sort of stepped in in the
wake of your departure
uh i didn't mind being categorized they
were two groups of family we called them
kind of my team and rudy's team
i i didn't mind being characterized as
being part of team normal as reporters
you know kind of started to do around
that point in time
um
you know i said you know hours ago early
on that
you know i've been doing this for a long
time um 25 years and
i've spanned you know political
ideologies from trump to mccain to bush
to christy you know and
you know i can work under a lot of
circumstances for a lot of varied
um you know candidates and politicians
but um
a situation where um
and i think along the way i've built up
a pretty good hope a good reputation
for being honest and and professional
and i
i didn't think what was happening was
necessarily honestly or professional at
that point in time so yeah that led to
me stepping away
so
the president did
get rid of team normal
and i'd like to play a clip showing that
the president found the people he needed
to perpetuate his claims of fraud
they saw a big truck
bringing in 100 000 ballots in garbage
cans
in waste paper baskets
in cardboard boxes and in shopping
baskets
and every single one of them was for
biden because they were being notified
by
smartmatic
in frankfort
that biden was way behind and they
better come up with a lot more balance
and we can prove every single thing i
just said
if you gave me the paper ballots i could
probably turn around
each one of these things
i'm absolutely convinced if you if you
let me examine each one of those ballots
i pull out enough
that were fraudulent
that it would shake the hell out of the
country
it can set and run an algorithm that
probably ran all over the country to
take a certain percentage of votes from
president trump and flip them to
president biden which we might never
have uncovered had the votes for
president trump not been so overwhelming
in so many of these states that it broke
the algorithm i remember that one of the
things mark said at some point was
you can't show an actual vote was
flipped
which i found at the time to be a
remarkable assertion
because
because
you don't have to
have the gun
to see the body lying on the floor
bleeding out with five bullet holes in
it was killed by a gun
what they were proposing
i thought was nuts
you know the theory was also completely
nuts
right there's a combination of the
italians the germans i mean different
things have been floating around
as to who was involved remember
yugoshove is in the venezuelan she has
an affidavit from somebody who says they
wrote a software in something with the
philippines just all over the radar did
you ever share mr kushner your view of
mr giuliani did you ever share your
perspective about him with the president
um
[Music]
i guess
i
yes
tell me what you said basically not the
approach i would take if i was you okay
and how did he react how did president
trump react when you shared that view
with him
yeah we said you know i
have confidence in rudy i think i had
conversations with probably all of our
council who are signed up to assist on
election day as they um disengaged with
the campaign
the general consensus
was that
um
[Music]
law firms were not comfortable
making
[Music]
the arguments that rudy giuliani was
making publicly
i seem to recall that i had a similar
conversation with
most all of them i made it clear i did
not agree with
the idea of saying nielsen was stolen
and putting out this stuff which i told
the president was [ __ ]
and uh
you know i didn't want to be a part of
it and that's one of the reasons that
went into me deciding to leave when i
did even sidney powell
defending herself in a defamation
lawsuit brought by dominion voting
systems
argued that quote
no reasonable person would conclude that
her statements were truly statements of
fact
mr chairman i yield back
i thank the witness for joining us today
the first panel
is now dismissed
uh without objection the chair
recognizes the gentlewoman from
california miss lofgren
uh thank you mr chairman
um last week
we presented the testimony of former
attorney general bill barr
who testified before this committee
today
we present additional evidence including
his testimony that former president
trump started making claims of election
fraud immediately after the election and
that barr concluded the claims were
untrue
now due to the length of attorney
general barr's testimony we're only
going to include relevant portions at
the hearing today so let's play
the video
the department in fact when we
received specific incredible allegations
of fraud made an effort to look into
these to satisfy ourselves
uh that they were without merit and and
i was in the posture of trying to figure
out
if there was an avalanche of all these
allegations of fraud that built up over
a number of days and it was like playing
whack-a-mole because something would
come out one day and then the next day
it would be another issue
also i was influenced by the fact that
all the early claims that i understood
on uh were completely bogus and silly
and usually based on complete
misinformation
and so i i didn't consider the quality
of claims right out of the box
to give me any
you know feeling that there was really
substance here
for the first time since the election uh
the attorney general spoke personally
with the president
on november 23rd and this was at the
white house let's play the video please
so on november 23rd i i hadn't spoken to
the president since the election and in
fact as i said since i'm the middle of
october roughly
and uh it was a little getting awkward
because obviously he had lost the
election and i hadn't said anything to
him and so cipolloni said you know i
think it's time you come over here
and uh so i
came over to meet with the president in
the oval office and meadows wood and
sipoloni
were there
and the president
and this is leading up to this
conversation with kushner
the president uh said there had been
major fraud and uh
that
as soon as the facts were out the
results of the election would be
reversed
and he went on on this for quite a while
as he's prone to do and
then he
got to something that i was expecting
which is to say that apparently the
department of justice doesn't think that
uh it has a role of looking into these
fraud claims so i said you know that has
to be the campaign that raises that with
the state the department doesn't take
side in elections and the department is
not an extension of of uh your legal
team uh and our role is to investigate
fraud and if we'll look at something if
it's if it's specific credible and could
have affected the outcome of the
election and and we're doing that and
it's just not
they're not they're just not meritorious
they're not panning out and as i walked
out of the oval office jared was there
with dan scavino who ran his
ran the president's
social media and who i thought was a
reasonable
guy and believe is a reasonable guy
and
i said uh how long is how long is he
gonna
carry on with this uh stolen election
stuff where is this gonna go
and by that time
meadows had caught up with me
and
uh leaving the office and caught up to
me and and said uh that uh
he said look i i think
uh that he's becoming more
realistic and knows that there's a limit
to how far he can take this and then
jared said you know yeah we're working
on this we're working on it
even after
his attorney general told him his claims
of election fraud were false
president trump continued to promote
these claims
i felt that things continued to
deteriorate between the 23rd and the
weekend of the 29th
and then on november 29th he appeared on
maria bartoromo's show
sunday futures i believe it was
and he said that the department was
missing in action well no we had
glitches where they moved thousands of
votes from my account to biden's account
and these are glitches so they're not
glitches they're theft they're fraud
absolute fraud this election was over
and then they did dumps they call them
dumps big massive dumps
in michigan and pennsylvania
and uh uh all over uh how the fbi and
department of justice i don't know maybe
they're involved
but how people are allowed to get away
from this
with this stuff is unbelievable
spurred by what he saw
barr told the associated press on
december 1st that there was no evidence
of election fraud and immediately after
attorney general barr's statement went
public mr trump berated and he nearly
fired barr but barb persisted in telling
the president that there was no evidence
to support the fraud claims
this got under my skin but i also felt
it was time for me to say something so
on
i had
i set up a lunch with the ap reporter
mike balsamo
and i told him at lunch
i made the statement um that today we
have not seen fraud on a scale that
could have affected a different outcome
in the election
i
had a later
meeting scheduled at the white house at
three o'clock with
meadows
uh this was previously scheduled so i
knew this was gonna
come up and i went over there and i told
my secretary that i thought i would
probably be fired and told not to
to go home
i mean not to go back to my office so i
said you might have to pack up for me
and uh so when i got over there i met
with the chief of staff he said the
president was angry
he didn't really go
get into the issue of the fraud
and then i went up to pat sipoloni's
office and we were talking with each
other
and the word came down that he wanted us
both to go to the oval
and the president was as mad as i've
ever seen him and he was trying to
control himself and the president said
well this is keeping on killing me
uh you didn't have to say this you must
have said this because you hate trump
you hate trump and then he raised the
the big vote dunk
as he called it in detroit
and
that you know he said people saw boxes
coming into the counting station at all
hours of the morning and so forth and i
explained to him
that i at that point i knew the exact
number of precincts of detroit i think
was 630 something i said mr president
there are 630 precincts in detroit and
unlike elsewhere in the state they
centralize the counting process they're
not counted in each precinct they're
moved to counting stations and so the
normal process would involve boxes
coming in at all different hours so
there's nothing
and i said did anyone point out to you
did all the people complaining about it
point out to you you actually did better
in detroit than
you did you did last time i mean there's
no indication of
fraud in detroit
and uh
i told him that the stuff that his
people were shuttling out to the public
were
[ __ ] i mean that the claims of fraud
were [ __ ] and uh
you know he was indignant about that
and um
i reiterated that they wasted a whole
month on
these claims on the
dominion voting machines and they were
idiotic claims and
i specifically raised the dominion
voting machines which i found to be
among the most disturbing allegations
disturbing in the sense that i saw
absolutely zero basis for the
allegations
but they were made in such a sensational
way
that they obviously were influencing a
lot of people
members of the public
that there was this
systemic
corruption in the system and that their
votes didn't count and that these
machines controlled by somebody else
were actually determining it which was
complete nonsense
and it was being laid out there and i
told them that it was it was uh
crazy stuff and they were wasting their
time on that
and uh was doing a great great
disservice to the country
okay so the very next day
the president released a video rehashing
some of the very same claims that his
chief law enforcement officer had told
him were quote
nonsense
here's an example
this is michigan
at 6 31 in the morning
a vote dump
of 149
772
votes came in
unexpectedly
we were winning by a lot
that batch
was
received
in horror
we have a company
that's very suspect
its name is dominion with the turn of a
dial
or the change of a chip
you can press a button for trump
and the vote goes to biden what kind of
a system is this
barr again told the president that there
was nothing to these claims
on december 14th
when i walked in
sat down he went off on a
uh
monologue
uh saying that there was now definitive
evidence
uh
involving fraud
through the dominion machines
and a report had been prepared by a very
reputable cyber security firm
which he identified as allied security
operations group and he held up the
report and he had i mean then he asked
that a copy of it be made for me
and while copy was being made he said
you know this is absolute proof that the
dominion machines were rigged
the report means that i'm going to have
a second term
and then he gave me a copy of the report
and as he talked more and more about it
i sat there flipping through the poor
report and looking through it and
to be frank it looked very amateurish to
me didn't have the credentials of the
people involved but i didn't see any
real
qualifications
and the statements were made very uh
conclusory like you know this these
machines were designed to you know
engage in fraud or something for that
effect but i didn't see any supporting
information for it
and i was
somewhat demoralized because i thought
boy if he really believes this stuff he
has you know
lost contact with with uh
he's become detached from reality if he
really believes this stuff
on the other hand you know when i went
into this and
would you know tell them how crazy some
of these allegations were there was
never
there was never an indication of
interest
in what the actual facts were in my
opinion then and my opinion now
is that uh
the election was not stolen by fraud
and uh i haven't seen anything since the
election that changes my mind on that
including the 2000 mules movie
[Laughter]
well maybe you can assess that 2000
mules and people are talking about that
well i mean just in a nutshell you know
i just think that the gbi was
unimpressed with it
and i was similarly unimpressed with it
because i think if you it because
uh i was holding my fire on that to see
what the photographic evidence was
because i thought well hell if they have
a lot of photographs of the same person
dumping a lot of ballots in different
boxes you know that's hard to explain
so i wanted to see what the photographic
evidence was but
the
uh cell phone data is is singularly
unimpressive i mean it basically if you
take two million
uh of cell phones and and figure out
where they are physically in a big city
like atlanta or wherever
just
by definition you're going to find many
hundreds of them have passed by and
spent time in the vicinity of these
boxes
and the premise that you know if you
go buy a box you know five boxes or
whatever it was you know that that's a
mule is just indefensible it it by
definition you're gonna have a lot
hundreds of this i mean one i saw one
contractor said we figured out that our
truck alone would account for six
cell phone signals
uh this was a
you know
some kind of contractor and you know our
route would take us by these things on a
regular basis so i i but then when the
movie came out uh
you know i think the photographic
evidence in it was completely
black i mean it was there was a little
bit of it but it was lacking you know it
didn't it didn't establish widespread
uh illegal
um
harvesting the other thing is people
don't understand is that
uh it's not clear that even if you can
show harvesting that that changes the
the results of the election you're not
the courts are not going to throw out
votes
uh
and then figure out what votes were
harvested and thrown out you'd still the
burden on the
challenging party to show that illegal
votes were cast votes were
the result of undue influence or bribes
or or there was really you know the
person was non-compass mentis
uh but absent that evidence i don't i
just didn't see courts throwing out
votes anyway i felt that uh
before the election it was possible to
talk sense to the president
uh and while you sometimes had to uh
engage in uh
you know a big wrestling match with him
uh that it was possible to keep things
on track but i was
felt that
after the election he didn't seem to be
listening and i didn't think it was uh
you know that i that i was inclined not
to stay around if he wasn't listening to
advice from me or his other cabinet
secretaries
so on december 14th
barr quit
now the attorney general wasn't the only
person who told the president that his
claims were false
other officials and close advisers told
him the same thing
rather than
try to address a counterfactual or a
hypothetical let me just say
there were instances where the president
would say people are telling me this or
i've heard this or i saw on television
you know this this impropriety in
atlanta or pennsylvania or something
we were in a position to say
uh
our people have already looked at that
and we know that you're getting bad
information if that's that's not correct
it's been
demonstrated to be
uh incorrect
from our point of view
a month and a half
or so after the
election day
and at that meeting
very you know various allegations of
fraud were discussed
um
and
you know
eric and pat
didn't
you know
told the group the president included
that none of those allegations had been
substantiated to the point where they
could be the basis for any
litigation
challenge to the election
president trump's own vice president and
his top advisors also knew that there
wasn't evidence to support the claims
that the president was making
anyone else other than mr meadows who
asked you
about the status outside of your legal
group you know mr morgan and the others
you mentioned and well to ask you the
status of what you were finding in your
assessment of it
uh yes sir
who's that peter navarro
when did you talk to mr navarro
um
mid-november
around the same time as
mr meadow
yes sir
and tell me about that conversation
um
i recall him asking me questions about
dominion
and
maybe some other categories of
allegations voter fraud
and i remember telling him that
i didn't believe the dominion
allegations
because i thought the hand recount in
georgia
would
resolve any issues with
a technology problem and
with dominion or dominion flipping votes
and i i mentioned at that time that
the sissa chris krebs had recently
released a report
saying that the election was secure
and i believe mr
navarro accused me of being an agent of
the deep state working with chris krebs
against the president
and i never took another phone call from
mr navarro
anyone else besides mr meadows mr
navarro mr hershman that you had
discussions
with uh
inquiring about what you were finding in
your
review of the allegations that were
pouring in
i believe i had about a 15 second
conversation with the vice president
about it as well
what was that
during one of the visits to the white
house
i don't know which one
i think it was the first one in november
i was i had met him
briefly at the campaign
and he remembered me and saw me
and uh
he asked what i was doing
on the campaign and i told him that you
know we were looking into
some of the issues related to voter
fraud
and he asked me i don't remember his
exact words but he asked me if uh
we were finding anything
and i said that i didn't believe we were
finding it or i was not personally
finding anything
um
sufficient to alter the results of the
election
and he he thanked me
that was our interaction
at a later hearing
you'll hear live testimony from the
former acting deputy attorney general of
the department of justice rich donahue
but now i'd like to play a portion of
his testimony
i tried to
again put this in perspective and to try
to put it in very clear terms for the
president
and i said something to the effect of
sir we've done dozens of investigations
hundreds of interviews
the major allegations are not supported
by the evidence developed we've looked
at georgia pennsylvania michigan nevada
we're doing our job
much of the info you're getting is false
and then i went into for instance this
thing from michigan this report about 68
error rate
the reality is it was only 0.006 3 error
rate less than
1 in 15 000.
so the president accepted that
um he said okay fine but what about the
others and again this gets back to the
point that there were so many of these
allegations that when you gave him a
very direct answer on one of them he
wouldn't fight us on it but he would
move to another allegation
so then i talked about a little bit
about the pennsylvania truck driver this
is another allegation that had come up
and
this claim was by a truck driver who
believed perhaps
honestly
that he had transported an entire
trip a tractor-trailer truck full of
ballots from new york
to pennsylvania
and this was again out there in the
public
and discussed
and
i essentially said look we looked at
that allegation we looked at both hands
both the people who load the truck and
the people unload the truck
um
and that that allegation was not
supported by the evidence
uh again he said okay
then he said no i didn't mention that
one
what about the others
and i said okay well with regard to
georgia we looked at the tape we
interviewed the witnesses
there is no suitcase the president kept
fixating on this suitcase that
supposedly had fraudulent pallets that
the suitcase was rolled out from under
the table
and i said no sir there's no suitcase
you can watch that video over and over
there is no suitcase there is a wheeled
bin
where they carry the ballots
and that's just how they move values
around that facility there's nothing
suspicious about that at all
um
i told them that there was no multiple
scanning of the ballots
one of the one part of that allegation
was that they were taking
one ballot and scanning it through three
or four or five times to rack up votes
presumably for vice president biden i
told him that the video did not support
that
[Music]
then he went off on double voting the
top of the next page he said dead people
are voting
indians are getting paid to vote he met
people on
native american reservations
he said there's lots of fraud going on
here hold him flat out that much of the
information he's getting is false
and or just not supported by the
evidence
we look at the allegations but they
don't pan out
mr barr and his advisers were not the
only ones who determined that the
president's allegations regarding
dominion voting machines were false so
mr chairman i ask unanimous consent to
include in the record of this hearing
reports issued by the department of
homeland security's cyber security and
infrastructure security agency otherwise
known as cissa
that addressed and rejected the claims
of manipulation of voting machines in
the 2020 election
without objection so ordered
thank you mr chairman i also ask
unanimous consent to include in the
record a report prepared by the michigan
senate oversight committee that disprove
claims of election fraud in michigan as
well as a statement by 59 of the
country's leading election security
scientists noting the absence of any
credible evidence that the 2020 election
had been altered through technical
compromise and five other reports from
organizations and individuals confirming
there was no widespread fraud in the
2020 election or describing the spread
of the former
president's lies
without objection so ordered
thank you mr chairman and i yield back
pursuant to the order
of the committee for today the chair
declares the committee in recess for a
period of approximately 10 minutes
[Music]
youtube didn't
you go
back down
i'm going to stay i'm just going to use
the restaurant
thank you
i was over there
how are you
huh
[Applause]
come on
[Music]
uh
okay
making sure
thank you
future
much
uh
yes
[Music]
okay
over here
okay
wow
few
so
perfect
so
okay
okay
committee will be in order
i now welcome our second panel of
witnesses
we're joined today by b.j pack
al smith and ben ginsburg
mr pack is the former united states
attorney for the northern district of
georgia mr smith is a former city
commissioner for the city of
philadelphia where he served for more
than 10 years mr ginsberg
is one of the leading election law
attorneys in the country and has
represented republican presidential
candidates
in election litigation dating back
to 22 000
where he represented george w bush in
the bush v goal litigation
i will now swear in our witnesses
please stand and raise your right hand
do you swear our firm on the penalty of
perjury that the testimony you're about
to give is the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth so help you god
thank you please be seated
let the record reflect the witnesses
answered in the affirmative
pursuant to section 5c 8 of house
resolution 503 i now recognize a young
woman from california miss lostman for
questions
thank you mr chairman
before the break i think you all heard
uh mr barr and mr donahue talk about the
false claims that mr trump and his
supporters made about suitcases of fake
ballots in georgia
we have a witness here today who
thoroughly investigated that issue
mr pack i want to thank you for
appearing before us today you were
appointed by president trump to serve as
a u.s attorney for the northern district
of georgia and you served from 2017
until january of 2021. you were the lead
federal prosecutor there and worked for
the department of justice under then
attorney general bill barr
now were you ever asked by attorney
general barr to investigate claims of
voter fraud in the 2020 election
and if so what were those claims
thank you congressman lofgren
thank you for the question
approximately december 4th i believe of
2020
attorney general barr and i had a
conversation about an unrelated case to
the case at issue
at the end of the conversation mr barr
had
asked me if i had seen a certain
videotape
that was being reported in the news
where mr
giuliani in a
senate subcommittee hearing that was
held the day before may 3rd
showed a videotape
of a purportedly
a security tape at the state farm arena
in atlanta which is also in fulton
county in the city of atlanta
i'm sorry city of uh yes
at the time mr
r asked me
that
he had
made a public statement that he had not
seen any
um
widespread election fraud that would um
question the um outcome of the election
and because the videotape and the
serious allegation that mr giuliani was
making respect to
these suicidal ballots reported in the
the video
he asked me to find out what i could
about it because he had envisioned that
in some days
after our call that he was going to go
to the white house for a meeting and
then that issue might come up
he asked me to make it a priority to get
to the bottom of
just try to substantiate the allegation
made by mr giuliani
thank you i understand the georgia
secretary of state's office
investigated those state farm arena
allegations and didn't find any evidence
of fraud what did you find when your
office convicted conducted its own
investigation
we found that the suitcase full of
ballots the alleged black suitcase that
was being seen pulled from under the
table
was actually an official lock box where
ballots were kept safe
we found out that there was a mistake in
terms of his
misunderstanding that they were done
counting ballots or tallying ballots for
the night
and the the partisan watchers that was
assigned by each of the respective
parties were announced to send home but
once they realized a mistake someone
from the secretary of state's office had
indicated that no no we're not done for
the night you need to go ahead and
continue counting
so once they packed up the lock box full
of ballots they brought back the
official ballot box again and continued
to tally the ballots from that
from the the lock box
unfortunately
during the senate hearing
mr giuliani only played a clip that
showed them pulling out the official
ballot box from under the table
and referring to that as a smoking gun
of a fraud in fulton county but in
actuality and review of the entire
video
it showed that that was actually an
official ballot box that would kept
underneath the
tables
and then we saw them pack up because the
announcement that they thought they were
done for the night
and then once the announcement was made
that you should continue
counting they brought the ballot back
back out and they continue to count we
interviewed the fbi interviewed the
individuals that are depicted in
the the videos
that purportedly were double triple
counting of the ballots and determined
that
nothing irregular happened in the county
and the allegations made by mr giuliani
were
false
thank you very much i'd like to
play again um
a testimony from mr donahue who appeared
before the committee before today
mr donahue you we talked at some lengths
about
whether or not the white house the
president was informed about the antrim
report
um
on the
results of the investigations the
interviews that had gone on on fulton
county
how would those results have been
communicated
to the white house to the president
i don't know how they were initially
communicated i do know that they came up
in subsequent conversations with the
president and dad rose and i essentially
told him we looked into that and it's
just not true
okay so he was and he was informed
i told the president myself that several
times in several conversations that
these allegations about ballots being
smuggled in in the suitcase and run
through the machine several times it was
not true that we looked at we looked at
the video we interviewed the witnesses
it was not true
mr pack after you left the u.s
attorney's office on january 4th 2021
did the next u.s attorney there i think
mr trump's personal pick bobby christine
did he investigate any remaining claims
of fraud
and if so did he find any evidence that
supported the president's claims of
voter fraud
it is my understanding that mr christine
continued any investigations that were
pending at the time of my departure but
he was unable to find any evidence of
fraud that affected the outcome of the
election
so after investigating the president's
and mr giuliani's claims about voter
fraud in georgia
is it your view today that there was no
evidence of widespread fraud sufficient
to undermine confidence in the outcome
of the election in georgia that is
correct
thank you mr peck and i want to thank
you also for the service you've given to
our country we appreciate that
next i'd like to turn to president
trump's false allegations about election
integrity in philadelphia the attorney
general discussed these allegations at
some length
you know the idea
the president has repeatedly suggested
that there was some kind of outpouring
of
unexpected votes in inner city areas
like philadelphia as recently as january
13th when he walked off the npr said
he was asked by the
interviewer what's
you know what's your evidence of fraud
and he said more people voted in
philadelphia than there were voters
and that was absolutely rubbish
the turnout in philadelphia was in line
with the state's turnout and in fact it
was not as
as impressive as many uh suburban
counties and uh
there was nothing uh
strange about the philadelphia uh
turnout it wasn't like there was all
these unexpected votes that came out in
philadelphia so
you know i think once you actually look
at the votes and then
there's an obvious explanation he
you know for example in pennsylvania
trump ran weaker than the republican
ticket generally he ran weaker than two
of the state
uh candidates he ran weaker than the
congressional delegate a delegation the
running for federal congress and he ran
weaker than the republic i think
uh i haven't looked at this recently but
he generally was
you know a weak element on the
republican ticket so that does not
suggest that the election was stolen by
fraud how about pennsylvania and bill
mcs wayne we were talking to the u.s
attorney in philadelphia about an
alleged discrepancy between the number
of absentee ballots issued in the number
of ballots right so you know that was a
one of the big ones for a period of time
i think i think that was raised in
gettysburg by giuliani or something like
that but it kept on being repeated and i
found it annoying because
uh
it didn't seem that it was right so i
called
i called mcswain
and uh
he got back to me said no the problem is
that austriana threw out a
throughout this number and what he did
was he mixed apples and oranges he took
the number of applications for the
republican primary and he compared it to
the number of absentee votes
cast in the general election but once
you actually go and look and compare
apples to apples there's no discrepancy
at all
and
you know that's one of the
i think at some point i covered that
with the president
we have another witness here today
who has detailed knowledge about the
election process in philadelphia
mr schmidt at the time of the 2020
presidential election you were serving
as the only republican member of
philadelphia's three-member city
commission which is responsible for
overseeing elections throughout the city
is is that correct
that's correct congress person
so president trump made numerous claims
regarding fraudulent voting practices in
philadelphia including the claim that
dead people were voting in fact mr
giuliani told pennsylvania state
legislators that 8 000 dead people voted
in pennsylvania you investigated those
claims of voter fraud
can you tell us what you found
not only was there not evidence of 8 000
dead voters
voting in pennsylvania there wasn't
evidence of eight
we took seriously every case that was
referred to us
no matter how fantastical no matter how
absurd and took every one of those
seriously including these
as it turns out even mr trump's campaign
lawyers knew that the dead voter claims
weren't valid
i guess the crooks in philadelphia are
disappointed in this they only submitted
8021
ballots from dead people
mail-in ballots for dead people probably
easier for dead people to submit mail
imbalance than it is to vote in person
rudy was at this stage of his life and
the same
ability to manage things at this level
or not
and obviously i think bernie carrick
publicly said it they never proved
the allegations that they were making
and they were trying to develop
mr schmidt on november 11 2020
president trump tweeted about you
saying and here's a quote
a guy named al schmidt a philadelphia
commissioner and so-called republican or
rhino
is being used big time by the fake news
media to explain how honest things were
with respect to the election in
philadelphia he refuses to look at a
mountain of corruption dishonesty we win
as a result of that tweet and the cnn
interview you gave where you stated the
dead voter claims in pennsylvania were
false
you and your staff were subjected to
disturbing threats can you tell us about
that
the threats prior to that tweet and on
some level it feels almost silly to talk
about a tweet but we can really see the
impact they have because prior to that
the threats were pretty general in
nature
corrupt election officials in
philadelphia are going to get what's
coming to them
you're what the second amendment is for
you're walking into the lion's den all
sorts of things like that
after the president tweeted at me by
name calling me out the way that he did
the threats became much more specific
much more graphic
and included not just me by name
but included members of my family
by name their ages our address pictures
of our home
just every bit of detail that you could
imagine that was what changed with that
tweet
behind me are redacted threats that you
received
that you provided to the committee now
we redacted portions of the text to
protect your family
mr schmidt i i think i speak for all of
my colleagues when i say we are deeply
sorry for what you and your loved ones
have been through
and i also want to thank you for your
service to your country and for standing
up for the rule of law
i want to thank both mr pack and mr
schmidt for their service their
testimony
and for standing up for the rule of law
now i'd like to turn to another subject
um
the courts in our country
provide a legitimate venue for campaigns
to challenge what they view
as irregular election practices now
courts have the final say on how the law
applies to those challenges
we have a renowned legal expert here to
address the trump campaign's activities
in court
mr ginsberg you spent your entire career
representing republicans in election
related litigation you served as the
national council on republican
presidential campaigns in 2000 in 2004
and in 2012.
you played a key role
in the 2000 florida recount that led to
the supreme court's decision in bush v
gore
you served as the co-chair of the
presidential commission on election
administration
i think it's fair to say you're the most
prominent republican lawyer who's
litigated in the election field now
you've analyzed the trump campaign's
litigation pretty uh carefully
what's the like normal process for
post-election litigation how is the
trump campaigns different from the kinds
of post-election litigation you've been
involved in and know about
in the normal course of things any
campaign on the night of the election in
the days after we'll do a couple of
different things one is that they'll
analyze precinct results to look for
abnormalities in the results and they'll
send people to those precincts to ask
more questions
secondly
uh all campaigns will have poll watchers
and poll work workers and observers in
the polling place and so campaigns will
talk
to those people if they saw any
irregularities that could cause problems
in the election now the trump campaign
talked pre-election about having 50 000
poll workers so presumably they did have
eyes on the ground in all these places
and so in the normal course of things a
campaign will analyze the reports that
come in
trump campaign had a couple of basic
problems however
number one the 2020 election was not
close in 2000 that was 537 and close in
this election the most narrow margin was
10 000
and something in in arizona and you just
don't make up that those sorts of
numbers
in recounts and when the claims of fraud
and irregularities
were made you've heard
very compelling testimony from mr
stephen from matt morgan from alex
cannon
about those claims and how
they didn't believe them
so that put the trump campaign on sort
of a process of bringing cases without
the actual evidence that you have to
have in which the process is designed to
bring out
so are you aware of any instance in
which a court found the trump campaign's
fraud claims to be credible
no there was there was never that
instance uh in all the cases that were
brought and i've looked at the more than
60 that include more than 180 counts and
no the simple fact is that the trump
campaign did not make its case
the select committee has identified 62
post-election lawsuits filed by the
trump campaign and his allies between
november 4th 2020 and january 6
2021
those cases resulted in 61 losses and
only a single victory which actually
didn't affect the outcome for either
candidate despite those 61 losses
president trump and his allies claim
that the courts refused to hear them out
and as a result they never had their day
in court
mr ginsberg what do you say about the
claims that mr trump wasn't given an
opportunity to provide the evidence they
had of voter fraud did they ha in fact
did they have their day in court
they did have their day in court about
half of those cases that you mentioned
were dismissed at the procedural stage
for a lack of standing the proper people
didn't bring the case or there wasn't
sufficient evidence and it got
dismissed on a motion to dismiss
but in the other there was discussion of
the merits that was that was contained
in the complaints and in no instance did
a court find that the charges of fraud
were real and it's also worth noting
that even if the trump campaign
complained that it did not have its day
in court there have been post-election
reviews in each of the six battleground
states that could have made a difference
and those ranged from the somewhat
farcical cyber ninjas case in arizona to
the michigan senate report that was
mentioned earlier the hand recount in
georgia
that mr pack addressed and in each one
of those instances there was no credible
evidence of fraud produced by the trump
campaign or his supporters
thank you
you know as mr ginsburg has explained
there are no cases where the trump
campaign was able to convince a court
that there was widespread fraud or
irregularities in the 2020 election
over and over judges appointed by
democrats and republicans alike
directly rebuted this false
narrative they called out the trump
campaign's lack of evidence for its
claims and the judges did that even in
cases where they could have simply
thrown out the lawsuit without writing a
word
you can see behind me a few excerpts
from the decisions in these 62 cases
the trump campaign's lack of evidence
was criticized by judges across the
political spectrum
in pennsylvania a trump-appointed judge
concluded quote
charges require specific allegations and
proof we have neither here
another trump-appointed judge warned
that if cases like these succeeded quote
any disappointed loser in a presidential
election
able to hire a team of clever lawyers
could flag claim deviations from
election results and cast doubt on
election results the list goes on and on
allegations are called quote an
amalgamation of theories conjecture and
speculation
in another strained legal arguments
without merit
unsupported by evidence
derived from wholly unreliable sources
a fundamental and obvious misreading
of the constitution
the rejection of president trump's
litigation efforts was overwhelming
22 federal judges appointed by
republican presidents including 10
appointed by president trump himself and
at least 24 elected or appointed
republican state judges dismissed the
president's claims
at least 11 lawyers have been referred
for disciplinary proceedings due to bad
faith and baseless efforts to undermine
the outcome of the 2020 presidential
election
rudy giuliani had his license to
practice law suspended in new york and
just this week a newly filed complaint
will potentially make his suspension
from practicing law in d.c
permanent
and as we've
just heard from perhaps the most
preeminent republican election lawyer in
recent history
the trump campaign's unprecedented
effort to overturn its election laws in
court was a deeply damaging abuse of the
judicial process as stated by u.s
district court judge david carter this
was quote
a coup in search of a legal theory
thank you mr chairman i yield back
i want to thank our witnesses for
joining us today
the members of the select committee may
have additional questions
for today's witnesses and we ask that
you respond expeditiously in writing to
those questions
without objection members will be
permitted 10 business days to submit
statements for the record including
opening remarks and additional questions
for the witnesses
the second panel of witnesses is now
dismissed
without objection the chair recognizes
the gentlewoman from california miss
lofgren for a closing statement
thank you
thank you mr chairman
now that we understand the litigation
efforts by president trump and his
allies i'd like to present additional
actions taken by the trump campaign
during this time
president trump continued to push the
stolen election narrative even though he
and his allies knew that their
litigation efforts
making the same claim had failed that's
worth pointing out that litigation uh
generally does not
continue past the safe harbor date of
december 14th
but the fact that this litigation went
on well that decision makes more sense
when you consider the trump campaign's
fundraising tactics because if the
litigation had stopped on december 14th
there would have been no fight to defend
the election and no clear path to
continue to raise millions of dollars
mr chairman at this time i'd ask for
unanimous consent to include in the
record a video presentation describing
how president trump used the lies he
told to raise millions of dollars from
the american people these fundraising
schemes were also part of the effort to
to disseminate the false claims of
election fraud
without objections
amanda wick and i'm senior investigative
counsel with the house select committee
to investigate the january 6 attack on
the united states capitol
between election day and january 6 the
trump campaign sent millions of
fundraising emails to trump supporters
sometimes as many as 25 a day the emails
claimed the quote left-wing mob was
undermining the election
implored supporters to quote step up to
protect the integrity of the election
and encourage them to quote fight back
but as the select committee has
demonstrated the trump campaign knew
these claims of voter fraud were false
yet they continued to barrage small
dollar donors with emails encouraging
them to donate to something called the
official election defense fund
the select committee discovered no such
fund existed
i don't believe there is actually a fund
quality election defense fund did you
first say the election defense fund was
another is i think we called it a
marketing tactic yes
and tell us about these funds as
marketing tactics
uh
just a topic matter
where money could potentially go to be
how money could potentially be used
the claims that the election was stolen
were so successful president trump and
his allies raised 250 million dollars
nearly 100 million dollars in the first
week after the election
on november 9th 2020 president trump
created a separate entity called the
save america pac
most of the money raised went to this
newly created pack not to election
related litigation
the select committee discovered that the
save america pac made millions of
dollars of contributions to pro-trump
organizations including one million
dollars to trump chief of staff mark
meadows charitable foundation
one million dollars to the america first
policy institute a conservative
organization which employs several
former trump administration officials
204
857 to the trump hotel collection and
over five million dollars to event
strategies inc the company that ran
president trump's january 6 rally on the
ellipse all of us here today do not want
to see our election victory stolen by
emboldened radical left democrats which
is what they're doing the evidence
developed by the select committee
highlights how the trump campaign
aggressively pushed false election
claims to fundraise
telling supporters it would be used to
fight voter fraud that did not exist the
emails continued through january 6 even
as president trump spoke on the ellipse
30 minutes after the last fundraising
email was sent the capital was breached
every american is entitled and
encouraged to participate in our
electoral process
political fundraising is part of that
small dollar donors use scarce
disposable income to support candidates
and causes of their choosing to make
their voices heard
and those donors deserve the truth about
what those funds will be used for
throughout the committee's investigation
we found evidence that the trump
campaign and its surrogates misled
donors as to where their funds would go
and what they would be used for so not
only was there the big lie
there was the big rip-off
donors deserve to know where their funds
are really going they deserve better
than what president trump and his team
did mr chairman i yield back
without objection the chair recognizes
the gentlewoman from wyoming ms cheney
for a closing statement
thank you very much mr chairman mr
truman i would like to thank all of our
witnesses today
uh and i'd also like to uh in particular
wish mr stephen and his family uh all
the best on the arrival of of a new baby
today's hearing mr chairman was very
narrowly focused
and in the coming days you will see the
committee move on
to president trump's broader planning
for january 6th
including his plan to corrupt the
department of justice
and his detailed planning with lawyer
john eastman to pressure the vice
president state legislatures state
officials and others to overturn the
election
let me leave you today with one clip to
preview what you will see in one of our
hearings to come
this is the testimony of white house
lawyer eric hirschman
john eastman called mr hirschman the day
after january 6th and here is how that
conversation went
i said to him
are you out of your f in
mind right
i said i
could i only want to hear two words
coming out of your mouth from now on
orderly transition
thank you mr chairman i yield back
at the conclusion of last week's hearing
we showed you a video of rioters
explaining
why they had come to washington on
january 6th
it was because donald trump told them to
be here
today we heard about some of the lies
donald trump embraced and amplified when
it became clear he didn't have the
numbers of votes to win the election
we heard about how officials at
different levels of government
exploit claims of fraud and found no
evidence
yet the former president continued to
repeat those false claims over and over
again
today
we'll end things where we did on
thursday
back on january 6.
hearing words of individuals who wanted
to stop the transfer of power
we know they were there because of
donald trump
now we hear some of the things they
believed
without objection i enter into the
record a video presentation
i know exactly what's going on right now
fake election
they think they're gonna [ __ ] cheat
us out of our vote and put
[Music]
[Music]
dominion software all over
we voted and right in the top right hand
corner of the dominion voting machine
that we used there was a wi-fi symbol
with five bars so that
most definitely connected
without a doubt so they stole that from
us twice
we're not doing it anymore we're not
taking it anymore so we're standing up
we're here
and
whatever happens we're not laying down
again
[Music]
what is it going to take
the chair requests those in the hearing
room remain seated until the capitol
police have escorted members from the
room
without objection the committed stands
are joined
again
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you